I wanted to ask you like everything that
you talk about I mean I actually listen
to it I think I have a pretty good grasp
about it you know making money having a
good job and everything spinning plays
in your 30s and 40s that's fine but then
what is the end game for men when they
go older like 50 and 60 what do you
think should be the end game if you have
money Define end game to me to me so I
understand what you mean I mean you know
even if you're in your 50s and 60s and
you end up with women when they're when
they're like 25 and 30 and they still
cheat on you and they still flake on you
MH you know you got to be there for them
for money you got to be there for them
for you know Vining them dining them and
everything so I mean what is the man
supposed to do in that age when when he
gets to that age you know okay so you're
talking about the endgame as it relates
to women and relationships I guess so
yeah yeah well look man like here's the
thing like I'm a product of the 70s
right you know people ask me how old I
am I just say you I was born in the 70s
so you know you can figure it out but
I'm I'm getting close to that
demographic um what's the end
game I don't know what's the best way to
answer that is me I mean to I mean to
give you an example of somebody who's
rich and famous I mean I mean like
DiCaprio he's in his 40s yeah and he's
been dating women all through his 30s
and everything but then when he's going
to go to the age of like 50 and 60
eventually he would probably need to
settle down with a woman he would
probably need to sim for her and then
have babies with her if he wants to do
it I don't know if he wants to do it
he's like the alpha male or something
who probably doesn't have to do any of
that [__] he can probably live to like
80 or 90 and then just keep dating
models and everything you know I mean
that's the way to go it it it really
depends on how you structured your life
how well you've unplugged from society's
comforting lies what your objectives are
and what your goals are um because when
you ask me the question you know I think
about it I'm like who [__] cares
right like she's there there she's not
there I mean do I want my girlfriend to
be there in the future yeah I like her I
dig her vibe but if she chooses not to
be there I'll be okay with that too
right um as far as like a guy like
Leonardo DiCaprio I mean if you look at
famous actors like uh like Robert
dairo um alpacino they're both old as
[__] like they're in their 70s and 80s
and they both just had kids yeah and
then I think Pacino is going through
some problems with this girl and
everything about the cares he's dude
he's got so much money he's just like
whatever I've scattered my seed one more
time I've got I don't know how many kids
has he got now seven or eight or
something like that right so it's like
he just gives the 20-year-old you know
whatever she needs she wants to bounce
he doesn't give a [__] he's 80 right um
you know the fact that he's able to
reproduce even at 80 he's probably just
happy with that so I think that the
question is what is it that matters to
you and how do you want to engineer your
life so that when you're older you know
as you say like as men grow older you're
getting what you want out of life like
I'm pretty sure Le Leonardo DiCaprio has
a plan I've never seen him interviewed
I've never seen him answer questions
around this that I'm aware of if
somebody's aware of it send me the
interview or the article or whatever is
out there but I've never seen it but if
I were to venture a guess I would
probably say Leonardo dicapro is
probably the kind of guy that will that
will start popping out a bunch of kids
uh maybe with one woman maybe with
multiple women and even at that point I
doubt that he's going to be faithful to
them because that's how he's run his
entire life or you could just get to the
point where he's like [__] it I don't
care I've already you know slept with a
bunch of women I've seen everything this
you know this one here is 10 out of 10
right so I'm going to dedicate you know
any spare time that I feel like jamming
into that with her so I mean you can you
can also take the example of Messi I
mean Messi was in love with the girl
since it was since his childhood and
then they have a family and Dave they
have kids he's got like tons of money is
worth like what $350 million or
something or for so I mean you can also
have those kind of Lifestyle where you
can have a family value and you can also
have a career but it's very hard for men
to actually find that kind of woman
nowadays because I mean in the past for
choice if you want to find that kind of
woman like if there's a unicorn kind of
woman that you uh
idealize no no they're not they're not
because I've been dating women in the
past two years I've been with like five
six women and dude every single game
plan turns to [__] when she starts
flaking and when she starts so then
doing her women thing you know I mean
yeah you just reper just like every
woman I've been with whether it's
somebody I've been seeing for like two
months or me mons it's is it sounds like
to me like you're investing too heavily
in the notion that it's going to turn
turn into something and you know I said
this earlier today on uh Twitter um hang
on a second let me just dig it up
because there was this there was this
viral clip that just went nuts on
Twitter uh with some girl that was being
interviewed and she said something along
the lines of um I need uh a goty to
spend at least $200 on a first date and
the guy interviewing her was like well
you know what are you doing for the $200
she well you get my presence you know I
have to spend money on makeup and all
this sort of stuff and yeah exactly
where is it here
uh man this timeline gets so congested
here on Twitter X I keep calling it
Twitter even though it's X anyway the
point that I was making is that you want
to choose women and invest in women that
are that that show you that they're
worth something first otherwise they're
worth nothing I like I can spend $2,000
on a date on a first date if I want I
don't give a [__] she she doesn't get a
dime of that she gets a coffee or a
drink if I if I'm single and I'm going
out dating she gets a coffee or drink
because that's that's all I have time
for I have one hour for them to
demonstrate to me that they're worth me
taking them out again because that's who
I am and that's where I see myself and
they're going to see that value because
of how I hold myself out to the world so
if she's into that if she's following
that lead if she's entering my frame if
she wants to spend more time with me if
she shows she has genuine burning desire
then I'll spend more time with her but
if she's flaky if she's disinterested if
you have to spend $200 to take me out a
day get [__] get F I have I have
options and I'm busy and I have things
to do right so the point that I'm making
here my friend is focus on you focus on
yourself build yourself up so that
you're in a position so that things like
this don't bother you you don't you
don't contemplate what's the end game as
I get older right you know that you have
options cuz because there's no end to
life like you know for me as it stands
right now I don't see an end game to
anything in my life I don't see an
endgame to me not working not traveling
like any of these things like I'll like
I'll do it as long as I'm physically
healthy enough to do it and I'm in great
shape and I take care of myself so I see
that as a very long Runway right so I
think this is more about turning around
you know like 180 degrees and rethinking
the way that you're approaching getting
older and looking at women does that
make sense it does I mean I'm I'm in my
40s I'm like 42 right now I have a six
bigger job I'm closing in about half a
million dollars in Investments and
everything so I have like a 10 to 15
year plan what do I want to do but I'm
just thinking when I'm 60 and 65 I mean
am I still going to be spinning plates
if I what do you want to do do you want
to have kids do you want to spin plates
do you want to rack up notches do you
want I already have a son when I was
younger I have a son so I'm probably
working so when when he grows up and I
and I tell him about the red stuff all
the time he's 12 and he knows so much
[__] about it that I'm just it just
scares me that I didn't know about it
when I was 25 that he knows at the age
of 12 so so so I want him to grow up as
a man who's some who's somebody who
knows about the okay but do you want to
have more kids no [__] okay so that's
fine so children focus on my son but
then I'm thinking about I want to make
money for him I want to be able to
settle down for don't don't ever make
money for your children show them like
you never give your kids fish you show
them how to fish yeah of course yes yeah
yeah um yeah spend the money on yourself
spend the money on your life enjoy it
but show them how to fish I I was just
thinking about like when you're 60 and
65 and if you're still are not able to
find the right woman do you have to keep
spinning plates until you drop dead or
like what the plan is I don't know I
think you're it still sounds to me like
you're too invested in women and making
them A Part of you feeling some level of
accomplishment as you get older like the
end game like to me the notion of end
game is like finish that you know when
when it comes to women now I don't know
what they bring to the table besides sex
right they don't really bring anything
they don't [__] bring anything
besides so why do you care about them so
much so why do you care about them so
much if because I guess that's all
you're saying it's it's just the way
that my parents were or my grandparents
were the family values and stuff and
yeah but that's cultural though right I
thought it was everywhere whether in the
US or in the mid midle East or something
I think families were there and they
were together for the sake of their kids
but now women have their own agenda
about oh if everything has to be about
me me me and the I know man because
women have changed like it's funny that
because there's a chapter in my next
book where I describe this Avatar of
Becky right and it's like this you know
this Avatar is like the modern woman and
she has her her own job she doesn't need
no man she's got her own apartment it's
furnished the way that she likes it she
has her friends she has her you know her
sisters and her little Network and they
do their stuff together and it's like
they keep hearing from all these
different angles a woman needs a man
like a fish needs a bicycle and it's
like look if if if that's the vast
majority of the women out there and
they're not suitable for long-term
relationships then just accept it you
know surrendering to the reality of the
world is a skill that you have to learn
as an unplugged man the Sun is hot water
is wet I cannot breathe if I try to walk
into the ocean underwater if I stay out
in the sun I will get a sunburn and I
will pay the price for that so you have
to surrender to certain realities of the
world and one of the realities of the
world that we live in today is women are
really not the greatest anymore they're
not generally marriage type of material
uh fewer and few of them are are worthy
of a long-term relationship or inviting
into your life in a longterm basis so
just accept that for what it is do your
thing Chase exellent spend time with
your kid hang out with a network of
topshelf men do cool [__] with them
right that's part of the reason why I
created my community this guys wanted to
do cool [__] and hang out with topshelf
men so if a girl comes along that fits
your frame and is a compliment to it not
the focus of your life and she comes to
you and says hey son of Krypton you know
we've been seeing each other for a while
um I'm not seeing anybody else where do
we stand you know where's this going I
really dig your Vibe and you look at her
and she's like okay she's got none of
the red flags or she's got one and she's
really working on right like she's
serious about you know being a good
compliment to your life that's when you
sit back and go okay maybe I'll
contemplate it see the funny thing is
that there was this one girl that was
really nice and everything but uh the
physical connection and everything the
sex it wasn't there it's just it's just
weird like some of the women you have
the best sex with they are crazy as [__]
I don't know how else to put it it's
just the way things are and then some of
the wom say so supportive and you don't
feel [__] with them in bed it's like
what the the hell is going on man why
can't I find that one woman where you
feel everything with her yeah and it's
and it's very difficult to find that
allinone check so I'll wrap it up on
this note because I've got a few other
people that I got to take in to yes sir
Absolut um as as women get older because
you're 42 so what age range you normally
dated uh the youngest I was with was
like 22 not over 30 for sure so
everything everyone was like between 20
to and 30 20 okay 30 so like as like as
women get older and you're dating
relatively young which is good for you
but as they tend to get older they tend
to accumulate more and more baggage yes
right he hurt me he cheated on me he
pushed me down the stairs he was a drug
addict he was an alcoholic he did this
or that and you know and then as they
get older they have you know more
opportunities to be with more men they
often become single mothers more often
they can have STDs more often they have
more abortions more often it's like all
of this [__] that they carry around is
just baggage and too much baggage yeah
they bring it into your life and it's
like you don't need any of that right
like if you're a man on a grind you're
putting a dent in the universe you're
successful you don't need that weighing
you down you just don't so again you
just look at it for what it is water is
wet the Sun is hot treat things as they
are don't expect them to be something
that they're not because they never will
be right like you can't have the
expectation of a chick that's shared her
body with 20 guys had two abortions uh
got beat up by one boyfriend had to DV
false DV like all these things that pile
up in their life in their head to be
good long-term relationship material
right like you need woman you need women
that hold themselves to standards and
are accountable and very few women can
do that today because they're told not
to I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out